die sonne ist anders als wir bisher
gedacht haben noch nie ist eine sonde
der sonne so nah gekommen und die
erkenntnisse sind schon jetzt zu beginn
der mission der packers dollar pro bahn
brechen und dafür hat die nasa die sonde
besonders geschützt denn ansonsten wäre
sie schon längst verglüht oder von mini
meteoriten durchlöchert worden
hightech materialien und konstruktionen
spielen so eine immer größere rolle und
mensch und technik bleiben dadurch in
zerstörerischen situation unversehrt
klicks umsatz im future gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts geht
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
heute habe ich übrigens ein kleines
ostern vielleicht etwas verspätet im
video versteckt seid also entspannt es
geht um diese high tech handy hüllen von
rainer steht für die gibt es nämlich
exklusive klicks umzuschauen
20 prozent rabatt eine woche lang danach
sind es immerhin noch 10 prozent wer es
nicht abwarten kann der kann ja schon
mal hier untersuchen
es sind die schwersten stürme im
sonnensystem die sonne bombardiert die
erde regelrecht mit ihrem sonnenstürmen
1,6 millionen kilometer pro stunde
erreichen sie für satelliten astronauten
und astronautinnen und raumschiff ein
großes problem denn diese strahlung kann
sie zerstören oder schwerverletzten und
auch unserer erde droht ständig gefahr
ohne unser magnetfeld würde die
atmosphäre einfach so von den
sonnenstürmen weggeweht werden wir
brauchen sie als schutz und auch die
packer soll ab ob brauchte einen
effektiven schutz sie fliegt nicht mit
einer schutzschicht um die sonne sondern
einer schutzwand 12 cm dick das format
protection system kurz gps ansonsten
wäre die sonde jetzt schon geschichte
und durch die sonne zerstört worden
die menschheit hat bei der entwicklung
von schutz techniken in den letzten
jahrzehnten riesige fortschritte gemacht
und das fängt schon im straßenverkehr
das fand ich bei dieser recherche
wirklich frappierend zu der mich reine
schild angeregt hat die ganz besondere
schutzhüllen für smartphones herstellen
seit siebzig starben noch 21.000
menschen in deutschland im
straßenverkehr siebenmal so viel wie
2009 10 trotz mehr verkehr heute
wir haben heute drei mal mehr pkw das
haben wir zu einem erheblichen teil
sicherheitstechnik wie abs esp
sicherheitsgurten airbags und viele mehr
zu verdanken hightech schützt unser
leben und es schützt technik wie bei der
packer soll abrupt auf die ich gleich
noch näher eingehen oder eben zum
beispiel vor allem unsere handys ein
produkt das wie kaum ein produkt zu vor
dem möglichen zerstörung ausgeliefert
ist wir haben es ständig in der hand und
hantieren damit und wie die erde durch
die sonne sind die smartphones damit
auch ständig einer bedrohung ausgesetzt
und seit jahren arbeiten die hersteller
von höhlen daran wie man diese hoch
empfindlichen geräte die auch noch wie
hier das iphone aus glas gefertigt sind
schützen kann
denn ein sturz kann verdammt teuer
werden der totalverlust ist schneller da
als man denkt und so arbeiten hüllen
hersteller an hightech materialien die
spielen eine immer größere rolle
myspace sex und tessa gibt es dafür eine
eigene abteilung die für beide
unternehmen arbeitet und zum beispiel
ermöglicht das chassis den unterbau
eines fahrzeugs aus einem teil zu
pressen kein anderer autohersteller ist
dazu in der lage und bei mobiltelefonen
da gibt es eine andere herausforderung
zur erinnerung es ist die raumzeit
krümmung also die die gravitation
verursacht und jedes objekt mit 9,81
metern pro sekunde im quadrat nach unten
zieht und für handys hat renault steht
inzwischen ein high tech material
entwickelt das so niemand vorweisen kann
schock spread danke an rheine spielt für
die unterstützung dieses videos ohne
euch welche nicht auf dieses thema
gekommen und der unterstützt unsere
arbeit auch finanziell
was wir gut gebrauchen können und ihr
habt auch etwas davon hierunter me und
am ende des videos und in der video
beschreibung und im angebunden kommentar
gibt es den rabatt schocks red ist ein
polymer also ein kunststoff der die
eigenschaften von zwei kunststoffen in
sich trägt nämlich zum einen
flexibilität und zum anderen
widerstandsfähigkeit eine handy hülle
muss nämlich weich und hart zugleich
seien weich um abzufedern und hartum zu
schützen eine eigenschaft alleine wäre
nicht ausreichend und die höhlen sind
trotzdem rund 20 prozent dünner als die
üblichen hüllen aus zwei kunststoffen
dadurch dass sie nur aus einem material
bestehen sind sie sogar leichter zu
recyceln
wir treffen den us militär fall
prüfstandards mls cd agee und
absorbieren stöße aus über dreieinhalb
metern höhe das ist auch nötig denn
unsere mobiltelefone sind auch ziemlich
heftigen kräften ausgesetzt wenn sie zu
boden fallen hierunter be gibt es noch
mehr infos und ich habe mir das nasa
design ausgesucht mehr geht nicht so
wird man iphone quasi zum hightech
geschützten nasa-satelliten absolute
hammer
und damit sind wir wieder bei der
parasol ab ob sie ist auch doppelt
geschützt denn zum einen muss sie die
millionen grad heiße sonnenstrahlung
aushalten
zum anderen ein ständiges bombardement
mit minimierten das ist quasi die
absolut schlechteste lage in die man im
weltraum geraten kann
aber die nasa hat das problem mit
hightech materialien gelöst gerade ist
die sonde zum siebten mal nah an der
sonne vorbei geflogen
es ist das erste mal in der geschichte
der menschheit dass wir einem stern so
nahe kommt sie ist der sonne inzwischen
rund doppelt so nahe wie die bisherigen
rekordhalter die helios sondern und am
nächsten punkt wird sie neun mal so nah
wie die helios sondern sein die vom
deutschen zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
und der nasa in den siebziger jahren zur
sonne geschickt wurden das sind 6
millionen kilometer etwa 4 sondern
durchmesser und das macht ein ganz
besonderes schild der nas ermöglicht die
sonde musste mich eine 650 mal stärkere
sonneneinstrahlung aushalten
ihr schild ist zwölf zentimeter dick
absolutes high tech material carbon
ihnen ein besonders leichter carbon
schaum außen vorne und hinten jeweils
carbon gewebe normalerweise wird karbon
in kunststoff eingegossen das ergibt
diese traumhaft glatten oberflächen zum
beispiel im auto und diese materialien
sind extrem widerstandsfähig nahezu
nichts kommt durch das eingegossenen
carbon gewebe durch kunststoff als
bindemittel macht aber in der sonne nähe
wenig sind das harz wurde abfackeln
das schutzschild wäre wirkungslos und
würde auseinanderfallen deshalb wurde
dieser prozess bereits hier auf der erde
kontrolliert durchgeführt nach dem
aushärten des kunststoffs wurde das
schutzschild mehrmals bei 3000 grad
gebacken das harz brannte ab
und es blieb nur das gewebe zurück es
hält jetzt die millionen grad heißen
partikel aus die ausrichtung der sonne
die sonde bombardieren wobei millionen
grad heiß wird das schutzschild nicht
das würde auch kein bekanntes material
aushalten
diese partikel sind so selten dass das
hitzeschild maximal 1400 grad celsius
heiß wird und die sonde dahinter wird
maximal 30 grad celsius heißt die sonde
fliegt in die millionen grad heiße
corona die atmosphäre rund um die sonne
um zu verstehen warum sie so heiß ist
denn unten auf der sonnenoberfläche ist
es mit nur ein paar tausend grad
deutlich kälter
wie kann es heißer werden obwohl man
sich von der hitze quelle entfernt das
soll die packers soll ab ob herausfinden
es ist ein absolutes rätsel und deshalb
muss ich so nah wie möglich an die sonne
herankommen und sie wird bis zum jahr
2024 immer weiter der sonne annähernd
bis zur entfernung von vier sondern
durchmessern und schon jetzt liefert sie
spannende erkenntnisse so verwirbeln die
sonnenwinde in der nähe der sonne viel
stärker und auch noch in großer
entfernung als gedacht und sie bilden
sogar zacken scharfe kehrtwende bei
denen sie wieder zur sonne zurück
gezogen werden es bleibt spannend welche
daten jetzt die packers oder probe noch
liefert und wie lange die sonde durch
hält genauso spannend wie es vielleicht
ist wie lange euer handy durch hält
schickt mir doch mal auf instagram
bilder eurer handys die einen sturz
vielleicht nicht so gut überstanden
haben bei handys sind wir ja noch lange
nicht so weit dass die geräte absolut
sicher sind rainer schild mit seinem
schock spread material könnte hier
sicher helfen hier klicken für mehr
infos und den sensationellen rabattcode
von 20% und ansonsten würde ich mal
sagen bis dann bleibt dran